okay emmanuel macron they're now taking
to the stage we're expecting to hear
from the french president the man who's
just won another five years very shortly
[Applause]
[Applause]
mercy thank you
[Applause]
thank you dear friends
dear patriots
first of all thank you so much
[Applause]
after
five years
of transformation
happy times difficult times
exceptional moments as well
on the 24th of april 2022.
majority of us have made the choice
which makes me very happy
and i shall preside for the next five
years
everyone who's carried out voluntary
work
our companions
who have been
accompanying me right from the beginning
and who've made this election
a possibility
when you really touch the heart you can
get to the truth
thank you i know what you've done for me
thank you so much
[Applause]
all
a stronger europe
and through investments and deep change
carry on ensuring concrete progress for
everyone by
assuring creativity innovation in our
country and in order to ensure that
france is a gra is a major
ecological
nation
i also
know
and a number of our compatriots have
voted for me
not
to necessarily support my ideas
but to act as a barrier to the extreme
right
and tell them that i'm aware that this
vote
will oblige me in the future years
to make sure that i'm a depository of
their sense of responsibility their
attachment to the republic and also
respect for the differences that have
been expressed over the past few weeks
[Applause]
[Applause]
i finally believe
[Music]
[Music]
i asked you not to whistle against her
so don't do that
because
from right now
[Applause]
that they voted for that project
we'll also find
an answer it'll be my responsibility
and
everyone that surrounds me
[Applause]
because
all the difficulties of lives lived and
to respond with efficiency to the anger
that's been expressed
my dear compatriots my dear friends
today
you have made a choice for a humanist
project independent ambitious for the
independence of our country for our
europe a project which is republican in
its values
a project that is a social project and
an ecological project
a project which is founded on work and
creation
[Music]
project of the freeing of our forces on
an academic level cultural level and
entrepreneurial this project
this
specific project i want to carry it with
strength in the coming years
by also being the depository
of the divisions that have
been demonstrated and the differences
and i want to make sure every single day
that
all are respected
and i want to work towards a fairer
society
and equality between men and women
hello
so in order to do so
it will have to be demanding and we'll
have to be ambitious we have so much to
do
the war in ukraine
exists
to remind us that we're going through
tragic times
where france
must
have its voice heard
and show the clarity of that choice
and to build up its strength in all
areas and we will do so
[Applause]
because
no one will be left by the wayside
it will be our responsibility together
to ensure this unity
and therefore we'll be able to live a
happier life in france and we'll be able
to face the challenges
that
are coming
for sure in the coming years the coming
years will not necessarily be
but they will be historical and together
we will be able to
make sure that
we cover them for our future generations
[Applause]
my dear compatriots
with ambition
and with care for our country for all of
us because
i would like to along aboard
along your side to deal with these five
coming years
it won't be easy
continuity of the previous five years
but it will be a
new method to try to ensure better years
at the service of our country of our
youth
[Applause]
each and every one of us
will have to commit themselves because
after all all of us
represent more than ourselves
and that's what really
makes of the french people
sources
strength that i love so deeply so
intensely
i am so proud of being able to serve
once again
[Applause]
france
[Applause]
we can see there the chairs of the
emmanuel macron supporters chanting one
and two and five more years
his victory speech he said he wanted to
see a fairer society with equality
between men and women where nobody is
left by the wayside but he was also
acknowledging
that he is leading a country that in his
words is full of doubts he said that he
was aware of the differences and he
wanted to respond to the anger at one
point he actually told her supporters
not to whistle out or boo marine le pen
because now he's no longer the candidate
of one party
but the president of everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you can see there on the stage
next to
the french president and his wife
he did note didn't he the number of
people who voted for him
not because they were supporting his
ideas but to act as a barrier to the
extreme right so you thank them as well
yeah he's acknowledged it it's i mean
it's a strange mixture isn't it it's
like a it's an emphatic victory a
convincing victory 16 points over his uh
vanquished rival but on the other hand
he knows it's it's qualified because a
lot of french people abstained and he
acknowledged that and
he said i'm the president of everyone
acknowledging his challenge and trying
to reach out to those people who felt
they had nothing to vote for in this
election
but also he acknowledged that a number
of a lot of french people voted for him
as a barrier to le pen rather than
voting for him the vote barrage is
calling in french um and
that's something he's got to live with
now you've got to try and get over that
and make up for it in the next five
years of his uh presidency and i think
the style of this victory rally is is
kind of acknowledging that it's
inclusive it's diversive he's he's um
shaking hands he's not striding to
victory on his own as he was in the
louvre palace five years ago he's
walking through the crowds at the head
of a
group of young people at the beginning
and he's shaking hands and he's
acknowledging he's got to reach out to
the french to those french
um who didn't vote for him and didn't
vote at all and try and uh get them on
site to try and heal all the divisions
we've seen open up in the selection yeah
as you say dominic it is a bit of a
strange combination isn't it because um
although as you said it's uh
he's managed to forge an alliance of
people who are
very supportive of him right through to
people who had to hold their nose all
the way into the polling stations just
trying to stop
the emergence of the far right
and yet
at the same time annabelle lever who
were also joined by as well
at the same time it does feel that he
has at least secured a mandate that is
strong enough that actually the next
five years could be a little bit easier
as a result
i hope so i mean it would be nice to
think that this has given him in a way
the room for maneuver now i mean the
republican party seems to have collapsed
so at that sense at least he's got some
room to move to the left and maybe try
and address the cost of living crisis in
the sense of
really of no future the lies behind so
many of the voters for le pen because
clearly
i mean some of the le pen voters clearly
are sort of let's be fluent they're
racist and they're xenophobic in the
west but clearly that's only a small
part of what's going on with le pen's
throat and it does seem like he really
needs to try and address the sort of
difference that he has left behind and
that's voting for le pen and for milosha
or that's simply abstaining and so i
hope that this sort of mandate really
gives him gives him the confidence also
to be a bit braver that way